all right Rita welcome back hi yes
so you were just telling me outside that
you you actually prefer to be living on
the street than been in the hospital
that you were in I don't want to go back
to the hospital I don't want them to
tell me what to do and they don't give
you seconds and when they give you your
medication and I'll be hungry when I get
up and what's important to me is I want
to be like these ladies and have nice
clothes and look nice but I was asked
when to visit a friend and I wanted some
food and they had a lot left and they
threw it away because in the Allisyn the
security said I'm nasty and other
disease and I got AIDS and they don't
want me and they build it because I'm
nasty and ugly and they be having
although the security's have meetings
about me and don't nobody like me
because I'm [ __ ]
and I said I'm special and they said
they don't want nobody who can't read it
right because they [ __ ] it dirty and
they do all the food away right now
and I almost was crying because I they
gave a girl some food that I'd be
visiting and it had a lot of food and
they wouldn't even get now not the god
of care and they told me to get back
they don't like me and I didn't do
nothing
so so you actually prefer I mean you
live on the street you don't even have a
tent right no I don't want to be by
myself
I want to be by myself I don't want to
be with nobody
only my mama at the hospital they keep
you locked up in a room and they you eat
it no oh and they give me medication but
when they give me food nothing
with this stuff they don't give me
second what is your typical day look
like here living in Skid Row I didn't
want to be like my friend she take me to
her house and give me clothes but she
makes me but she tell me to go make some
money and pay for her clothes because
she doing it cuz I'm her friend but she
need help too so your typical day here
on the street is what what do you do I
walk around and I I just be happy I
talked to my mother to my mother said
she's coming back my mama says she's
gonna come back my mother told me and
God my mother tells me that just stay to
myself and then she I go and sit under
on the corner and then a man stops
sometimes they look at my body I they
give me money and they take me to eat
and so people are nice to you on the
street or mean to you or some people's
is nice good I just want to be by myself
cuz when they nice I gotta get them
money when I don't feel like giving
making money I just feel like just
please me and God and my mother but I
have to okay be on this stage did you
get robbed sometimes ha have you been
robbed a few times
no I give it to them if they tell me to
I share anything I got because God got
it
bless but only thing happened to me as I
get my sugar bowl tip yeah they take my
sugar bowl down there a lot of time they
take sugar bowl they kill me you know
sometimes honesty they gave me rocks and
then they said let's party I don't want
none from you and then when I party I
gotta give up my body and then I just do
it so they won't kill me and my money
and yet you still prefer to live on the
street than in the hospital yeah because
nobody like me
Sarita tell me about your mom and dad my
mom and dad when I was young my dad and
monkey drunk he used to drown my mom and
a bad tub and put the water on and make
it a real real hot and she'd be
screaming and then I'll hold her in each
other it's okay he told me to shut up
and I go in there and run out the
bathroom and get a broom and hit him in
the back of his head and stuff he run
after me my mom I hurry up and get out
the bath and run out the door go call
the police my dad he when they not
drinking he goes he don't got time for
my mom my mom said that's not my dad
they were just young and partying and
she got pregnant by but she wanted us to
know our dad but he tried to kill her a
lot of times and I run in a closet and
come up with some clothes on my head and
I be scared and running a closet shut
the closet cover my head up because I
don't want to see it and then when he
made my mom bloody he rot me she had
locked the door and come again
so walk to me while she cleaning herself
up my I still be with my mom I love my
mom good my sister live in Sacramento
she called me [ __ ] too then she
don't want my nieces and him around me
but they said did I'm wearing the same
clothes I got the virus and I'm ugly
[ __ ] and she made him leave me alone
but I go to the unit station and they
help me and I give it to her so I would
be cold only one is cold and rain I
could stay with I think you're wearing
the same clothes well because I couldn't
get not with the money I gave herself
and then I bought some food for her
house and then I bought so rock but I
bought food actually brought rocking
yeah I gave herself
you mean crack well yeah I didn't buy it
I'll give her some money huh give me
some time but I take everything to her
and that's it I just go it buy the stuff
food first I don't buy drugs cuz they
take my money
I don't I just I let somebody give it to
me all right yeah
you know mostly my peoples they don't
like me last night security he was
calling me all kinds of nasty a
prostitute and said all of the
Securities being laughing every day and
talking about me and having a meeting of
how [ __ ] i am and that said and I'm
not good like these people and my mother
told me I was just special and different
but they said I'm [ __ ] to be around
them I need to learn how to read and the
dress better didn't I do you dress
beautifully it's clean but lady who is
here she don't want to give me no more
clothes you call this I'm cold
I get up yeah but I'll get on the train
and when this bill cold I get on the
train and at her house I got a
medication
I got a pump and I machine and inhaler I
got great wasn't in an orange jacket I
got yeah you got a good man he gave me
that jacket him that he had it all laid
on the ground and he gave it to me that
might give you something a little warmer
maybe okay where do you normally sleep
me yeah at the the most people when I'm
scared cuz at one person tell me that
they want my body and I got if I got
money I said you some money but please
don't take my body and then I just go
catch the bus real fast when I give him
the money and samo go somewhere there
Bobby selling the snap
tell her it's dirty and I'll get on the
bus and go to change you don't you don't
get money from Social Security or
anything no sir
so everybody I've got I got the letter
and anything that is gonna help me so
but right now the only money that you
get is from the money you make on the
street yeah I asked for donation people
that the grocery still give me food and
I take it to her so it this year but she
my best friend she try to help me and
then we play a little game of alphabet
since I got puzzle I read I'm gonna I'm
gonna make your day a little easier at
least well thank you for coming in again
yeah you guys sound fooled here I have
some money for you I got some food you
can go anywhere you like for luck okay
I'm gonna go across the state right now
missing kids and this Caucasian guy cuz
I got stabbed - he's a truck driver but
he live in Big Bear and he only come
once a month an image and since I came
to California but he don't know more
because they told them that I can't ride
with him on the road and it's too far
for them to come yeah if you ever get in
a jam you come see me okay okay if you
ever need help with anything
yeah thanks yeah well thank you thank
you for coming in thank you yes and I'm
a movie star I total a movie they put
the wires it yeah
I wanted to be on Dancing with the Stars
when I came here who's that when you got
me so close and I'm not obscure to go go
and I've got some two new shoes my God
my brilliant in my life I got a lot of
pretty clothes over their long lenses
cheap but with the money I gave you
yeah oh I see okay look at you you look
beautiful stop it's good you look so
stylish you're beautiful yeah you look
cuter than they do you look great yeah I
need a coat and a coat and a radio yeah
I got a coat right I got two coats for
you right here